similar to groundhog rules shattering
your clavicle on a rope swing means
summer is officially over
[Music]
summertime is a joke in this country you
know the dumbest kids on the planet
don't deserve a three-month vacation I
think a good rule of thumb is if Eminem
won't say it you probably shouldn't say
it your sophomore English class I will
never say any form of nigga
you know I'm period of that starting now
I'm never saying it again this fall the
Wardrobe will be over priced concert
tees wait whiffed sexy stubble high
school game day brought to you by
Clearasil and Planned Parenthood beaver
said me and my girl are gonna have lots
of sex watching tosh point-o when we
want to laugh we'll watch The Daily Show
okay that's okay time to say goodbye to
rope swing season
and hello to rooftop Caesar
[Applause]
[Music]
finally it's your last chance to get one
more BB Q in before the summer ends so
get those weenies on the grill a nice
char will offset the taste of burning
pubes don't break it
all the juices will run out is she done
go ahead and stick that on the toasted
buns it helps to butter them first
you